[Music]
for the start of his first trip abroad
president biden looked like he'd flown
right home again
but he'd chosen an audience of u.s
military and suffolk
to send this clear message to the west
and its rivals
at every point along the way we're going
to make it clear
that the united states is back and
democracies of the world are standing
together
to tackle the toughest challenges and
the issues that matter most to our
future
that we're committed to leading with
strength
defending our values
and delivering for our people it's taken
the president seven months to get out of
america
but the same threat that's kept him at
home will preoccupy him here
he's brought with him a promise to fund
hundreds of millions of covered vaccines
worldwide
america will lead the free world again
say officials
tackling what they call the three c's
covid climate change
and china ahead of the weekend's g7
summit the president meets britain's
prime minister
who spent the day highlighting the uk's
efforts to reverse climate change
and talking about a fourth sea cornwall
what we're looking at
is making sure that we have a new treaty
on
on pandemics working to that building
back greener
uh building that better which is why
we're looking at what's going on here in
cornwall with all the
with all the green technology but also
talking about the the values we have in
common
everything that we want to do together
there's a huge agenda there are points
of friction between president and prime
minister
northern ireland in particular but
observers say there's too much at stake
to let any of that get between them this
speaks well of britain really a leading
role
and that everyone is
realizing that this is a a pivotal
moment where we can either be working
together
to ensure that the future is not along
the lines of china and russia
and if we don't work together then
there's all
likelihood that the world will look very
different in 10 15
20 years face-to-face diplomacy is back
first for the prime minister and
president
than all g7 leaders meeting together a
lot has changed though since they last
met
covid worsening climate change the rise
of china
it'll take unity and determination for
the west to meet those challenges
head on the president has come with a
rallying cry to the west's richest
nations
if they fail to act rivals and autocrats
are waiting in the wings dominic waghorn
sky news falmouth